JULIE PEARL: Setting
this up, I believe
this was introduced as a
totally awesome fireside chat.
So I really hope that it
lives up to that expectation.
All right.
And so I am really excited
to have the opportunity
to do this fireside
chat today with Alaina.
Alaina, as you know, is
the CEO of Women Who Code.
And she started her
career working for Puma,
and after Puma, went
and got her MBA,
eventually worked
for a company and was
helping to design the first
volleyball and basketball shoes
designed exclusively for women.
And she eventually
moved into technology,
and that led her to a
path where now she's
the CEO of Women Who Code.
And I think the fun fact
here is that she's visited,
I think, 60 countries, and
she also loves chocolate.
So please help me in
introducing and welcoming Alaina
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Thank you.
JULIE PEARL: OK, so
tell us a little bit
about Women Who Code.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: First
off, how many of you
heard of Women Who
Code before today?
I'm glad I saw a couple
hands go up in the room.
Women Who Code is a
501(3)(c) nonprofit dedicated
to inspiring women to excel
in technology careers.
We're in 15 countries.
And this week, we're proud to
announce that we've exceeded
25,000 members globally.
JULIE PEARL: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAINA PERCIVAL:
Women Who Code focuses
on providing an
avenue into technology
and providing mentorship
and learning opportunities
so that women both stay in their
careers and make it to the top.
We've tripled year over year
since we've been created.
And we've launched last
week in Mexico City.
And the week before, we launched
in our first city in Africa.
So we're now in Algeria.
So that's another very
exciting thing to announce.
So I'm really excited
to be here today.
We're producing over 500 free
technical events for women
every year.
And we've got this
great movement growing.
And we're able to produce
all of these events
through our global
network of leaders.
And so that's something
that I'm really
interested in discussing today--
how we're able to do that.
JULIE PEARL: That's great.
Well, maybe you could share with
us some of the success stories,
and tell us about
some of the women
in the community that are
part of your organization.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: So
Women Who Code, our 500
plus technical events are
produced by our directors
and leaders around the world.
And so these are
primarily technical events
where you're learning Android,
or JavaScript, Python, Ruby.
We're giving women
opportunities to speak.
Maybe you give your first tech
talk at a Women Who Code event.
And then perhaps you'll
go back to your office,
and you'll give that talk there.
And then maybe
you'll expand on it,
and give that talk
at a conference.
So these leaders,
what we've seen
is, after you've
been a Women Who
Code leader for about a
year, that you actually
begin to become a leader in
the tech industry in general.
So you start to get asked to
come in and speak to companies,
and talk about best practices.
So you're a thought leader.
You get voted in the press
as 30 under 30 Women in Tech.
And we also see that they
start getting invited
to speak at conferences.
So you're really shifting from
being a leader of Women Who
Code to a leader in
the tech industry
in general, which is something
that we're really trying to do.
And today, we actually
have our leader
from Atlanta in the audience.
And that's just an
absolute coincidence.
And when she first stepped up
to be the leader in Atlanta,
she was not sure about it.
She was not sure that she'd
be able to do it well.
She hated to stand up at the
front of it a very small room
and say, hey, my name's
Erica, and today we're
going to be learning Android.
And if anybody has
questions, you can ask me.
OK, I'm going to sit down.
But she stood at the front
of the room for over a year.
And she talked to
people in the community.
And this autumn, she
was invited to speak
at three different conferences.
She actually gave a talk to
a standing room only crowd.
And she's an awesome engineer.
If she'd applied to
speak at a conference,
she probably would
have gotten in.
But she probably never
would've applied.
And she probably
wouldn't have been
asked to apply had
she not stepped up
as a leader in Women Who Code.
JULIE PEARL: You know,
it's kind of interesting
talking about her,
because I think many of us
sometimes feel like
maybe we're not
good enough in certain things.
So I'm kind of curious.
If any of you kind of felt
like you weren't good enough
to be doing the job that you're
currently doing-- a couple
hands.
Sometimes it's called
the impostor syndrome.
I like to call it fraud complex.
It's the way I always like,
I don't know how I got here.
And so some of the advice
that we're given is,
you should fake it
until you make it.
Not sure what that
means, but I'm kind of
trying to follow that advice.
I'm kind of curious,
what have you seen,
and any advice that you have
for women in this situation.
And maybe based on
your own experiences--
because I read an
article recently,
but you kind of made a
comment that you felt this way
at one point in your career.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: I definitely
felt this way myself.
I'd been working with Women
Who Code for over two years.
I was a leader in
the organization.
And I had come into
this role without ever
having the goal of becoming
a software engineer.
I wanted to learn how to code,
and I did learn how to code.
It's really fun.
But I didn't have the goal of
becoming a software engineer.
And so I thought, well, I can't
run an organization getting
women to become and excel in
careers in software engineering
if that's not who I am.
And so finally, I just had to
say to myself, you know what?
If a software engineer
takes this role,
then we're actually going
against our mission,
because she wouldn't
be a software engineer.
So I guess I can do this.
And so I had to
actually convince myself
that it was OK for
me to step up and be
a leader in the organization.
Actually, you have a pretty
amazing story as well.
Would you be
willing to share it?
[LAUGHING]
JULIE PEARL: Who's interviewing
who in this [INAUDIBLE]?
ALAINA PERCIVAL: [LAUGHING]
JULIE PEARL: [LAUGHING]
So Alaina and I
were chatting earlier.
Suzanne mentioned when
I had this opportunity
to go to Motorola, I was working
at Google on acquisitions.
And I was involved
in a lot of the work
up until the point where Google
actually acquired Motorola.
And at that point,
I was asked if I
would go and be the CIO,
at which point, my eyebrows
went up, similar to somebody
here in the front row.
Me?
I'm like, there must be
somebody sitting behind me.
And I really, I couldn't
believe that somebody
would actually have
considered me for that role.
And it really took me awhile.
I mean, it was a
huge opportunity.
It was a huge organization.
I was taking on a team of 600
employees, 600 contractors.
I'd managed a team of
about 150 at max before.
So it was one of those
opportunities where
I kept saying, I can't
possibly be qualified for it.
But everyone kept
saying, no, we actually
want you to take the role.
And I did.
And what I'll say is I
learned a lot about myself
through the process.
And I think-- I
read a lot about,
sometimes we have to take
the opportunities that
are presented sometimes, even
if they seem like they're well
beyond something
we can actually do,
because everyone knew
that I hadn't been a CIO.
I had a lot of resources, a
lot of people, a lot of advice,
a lot of mentors.
And it was really incredible.
And the good thing is that now
I've learned a lot about myself
through that, which
is really important.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: So
with Women Who Code,
we really work to make sure that
you have a network of people,
so that when you start to run
these things through your mind,
like can I be the
CIO of Motorola?
Yes.
Yes, you can.
That's fantastic.
JULIE PEARL: Should have
called you at the time.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: [LAUGHING]
Or I've been in my role
for two years.
When is it time to
ask for a promotion?
Or am I ready to
start interviewing
to become a software engineer?
Yes, go ahead and do it.
They're not going to give
you a job until you're ready.
So just go ahead and do it.
And so having that network, and
building those relationships,
and being really authentic
from the beginning,
it doesn't matter if your goal
is coming out two years later,
or five years later.
You're taking those
steps, and it becomes fun.
And what happens is that those
opportunities open up for you.
JULIE PEARL: That's great.
So Google's developed
this program
we call Unconscious Bias.
And--
ALAINA PERCIVAL:
Thank you for that.
JULIE PEARL: Yeah, it's
really fascinating.
And employees are going through
this training by which we're
really learning about what--
in many ways, how decisions are
being made, and what the
information is that we're
using to make those decisions.
And I'm kind of curious,
your take on examples
of unconscious bias that
you've seen that maybe you
could share with us.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: So I think this
one is incredibly important.
And as I'm saying big numbers
like, hey, Woman Who Code,
our goal is to reach
a million women.
We're currently
reaching over 25,000.
Actually, I'm realizing
that we have a lot of power
with the over 100 companies that
are supporting Women Who Code.
And so what we're
hearing is, hey, it's
not some big dramatic thing that
causes you to run out the door.
It's little tiny things
that are happening day
after day that make
you wonder if this
is the right career
for you, make
you wonder if you're good enough
for the role that you're doing.
And so I hear everything from
I create colorful spreadsheets,
and my team makes fun of me.
Or a woman told me
recently-- and she's
in a very senior position.
And she was working
with a French colleague,
and he said, oh, I've never
had to explain infrastructure
to a woman before.
And she's like, just
imagine me to be Tom.
I've got this.
Don't worry.
And those are really clear.
But then there's the more
subtle things that-- project
distribution, something
that you were really
wanting to get on that
other people somehow
managed to get on it.
And you know, was
I not good enough?
Was there hidden bias there?
And so it's sometimes
easier to process
the things that
are clearly like,
oh, they just didn't get it.
But sometimes, there's the
more subtle things that
make you wonder, was it me?
And they're little,
little tiny things
that happen day after day.
But I think that with hidden
bias training and building
awareness that
this exists, we're
able to process it better, and
hopefully improve the workplace
environment, so that it's
happening less frequently.
JULIE PEARL: I work with
some female engineers who
have been complaining recently
because we've had some events
with the outside community.
And they often believe that the
Google engineers at the event
are coordinating, or
part of marketing,
and they're not being recognized
immediately as engineers.
And how do we make sure that
even other people at the event
can call people
on that behavior,
and not making assumptions
about what people's roles are?
ALAINA PERCIVAL: I
had a couple of women
who had come to Google I/O, and
this was not at a Google event,
but it was at an after party.
And this young engineer was
like, well, why are you here?
And they said, oh,
we're Android engineers.
We're here for the conference.
And he was mortified, of course.
JULIE PEARL: We have a
lot of improvement to do.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: That
was completely unrelated.
JULIE PEARL: Oh, yeah.
So we've seen a lot of
companies recently releasing
their diversity data.
And I think it's a great thing
in terms of being transparent.
But obviously, we have
a long way to go there.
What do you think
companies can do
to increase the diversity of
their employee population?
ALAINA PERCIVAL: So these
numbers when they come out,
they are disappointing.
But the fact that companies
are putting this information
out there is a commitment
to seeing change.
So this is incredibly exciting.
And so the next steps are, like
you said, how do we do this?
And one is increasing
the pipeline.
Two is making sure that you're
reaching a broad community
in your recruiting.
And then the other side is
that numbers are coming out,
like 56% of women are leaving
their technical careers
at the mid-career level,
after about 10 years.
And this is a major
leaky bucket issue.
And if we can't correct that,
we're not going to reach 50%.
Women aren't a minority.
Women are actually
51% of the population.
And so really
working-- and I think
that Google's in an
amazing position,
because you love doing research,
and you have the ability
to find out really
what's happening here,
and how can we change it.
And so really
creating opportunities
where women understand
that, hey, there
are next steps in your
career-- creating mentorship
and advocacy programs in the
company, checking to make sure
that there's not a wage gap.
And it's tough to tell a company
to make a decision that's
not fiscally responsible.
But the reality is is if you
know that you're earning less
than your male counterpart,
and you have an opportunity
to change careers, or
you have an opportunity
to drop out of
your career, you're
a little bit more
likely to do that.
And so you're missing out on
that 20 years of a woman's
career where she is in the most
senior position, where she's
providing the most
value to the company,
and when she's
also in a position
to be mentoring and
leading everyone,
but definitely women
coming into the industry.
JULIE PEARL: Yeah, I found this
report to be really alarming.
You know, seeing a lot of
women leave their career
at the 10-year mark.
It's like, where are they going?
But have you seen
the specific things
that companies are doing that's
really helping keep women pass
that 10-year mark on average?
Or examples?
I think some companies are
starting to look at job shares.
Are there other things besides
the mentoring and the job share
that you mentioned that
could be relevant here?
ALAINA PERCIVAL:
Yeah, well, certainly
having a lot of
advocacy programs,
so making sure that
women have mentors,
creating a culture
of celebrating women,
and making sure
that-- right now,
it's not completely
comfortable for women
to talk about the
successes in their careers.
And it's not completely
comfortable for society
to hear that.
So if you can have
people advocating
for you in the company, that's
certainly going to help.
Doing the research.
Talking about hidden biases.
I was giving a talk, or I
was on a panel recently,
and an engineering
manager from the audience
actually read a
review that he'd done.
And then he went through
and-- he'd already
done this-- analyzed every
single thing that he'd said.
And so there was
like, oh, you know,
I'm not sure that she's as
enthusiastic about the company
because she's leaving at 6:00.
But there's another guy on
the team who also has a child,
and he's leaving
at this time too,
and why haven't I've
written this in his review?
And so it was really interesting
and incredibly revealing
to these little tiny things
that were the hidden biases.
Certainly, that's another thing
that companies can be doing.
But creating clear pathways
for leveling up in your career.
Having plans around distributing
great projects among team
members, and really
making sure that there's
opportunities to stay and
level up in the company.
JULIE PEARL: That's great.
So people used to ask me, what
is one thing that you observe
that women do quite a bit?
And something I've noticed
is I go to a lot of meetings.
That tends to be my job now.
And there's the main table,
and then sometimes there's
seating on the outside of
the room, the overflow.
And my observation is is
that I see a lot of women
sitting at the outside.
They don't sit at the table.
And so I observe
this quite a bit.
And now I encourage, if I'm
the one running a meeting,
I will actually call various
women from the outside to say,
you need to sit at
the table, especially
in engineering teams, where
it's more male-dominated
and the numbers
are fairly obvious.
What observations have you seen,
just like a behavioral thing
that you see women doing that
men aren't, that you could sort
of advise this group
as some takeaway
that they could do
starting tomorrow?
ALAINA PERCIVAL:
Bragging on yourself.
And that sounds terrible.
But the truth is, if you
don't champion your successes,
it's not going to get heard,
and so definitely making sure
that people know that
you lead this project,
that you received a promotion,
that you're giving this talk,
and getting the word out there.
And that's how you're going to
make the difference between,
hey, here's two
great people who've
been contributing
in this company.
This is who we're
going to promote.
Oh, I heard about
this person, and we're
going to try and get her to come
over and join our company now
in a higher position.
JULIE PEARL: So this
is kind of relevant.
There's this new
initiative, Applaud Her,
that you're doing
with Women Who Code.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
ALAINA PERCIVAL: So this
goes back to the whole idea
that it's a little bit
difficult for women
to celebrate the everyday
successes in their careers.
And every time I talk
about it, I'm like,
does this really exist?
Am I crazy when I'm saying it?
Is everybody going to
start shaking their head?
And recently, I was
speaking with a woman who
was director of engineering.
And she said, you know what?
I'm now senior director
of engineering,
and I've been too embarrassed to
put it on my LinkedIn profile.
And this is crazy.
She was too embarrassed to put
it on her LinkedIn profile.
So it absolutely exists.
And so Applaud Her
is a theme that Women
Who Code is weaving into
every single thing that we do,
because one of our
long-term impacts
is that we want it
to be comfortable
for you to talk about the
successes in your career.
So Women Who Code's
"Diverse Code,"
it's a newsletter that we
send out on a weekly basis,
one of the things that
we include in there
are your successes.
So please, of course, sign
up for the "Diverse Code"
at womenwhocode.com.
But please send
us your successes.
We want to be celebrating you.
And you're all having these.
Actually, who's been promoted
in the past six months?
Who launched a really
awesome product?
Who did something else
great that I haven't asked?
Come on, everybody's hand
should go up at that.
Yeah, so we want
to hear from you,
and we want to make
sure that we're
talking about these things.
And so, it's a combination
of definitely celebrating
you, making sure that the world
knows that there are actually
a ton of smart, ambitious, and
qualified women in the tech
industry, and making sure
that you know it's OK for you
to be talking
about these things.
JULIE PEARL: So in the spirit
of speaking up and promoting
yourselves, we're going
to actually open it up
for a few questions.
So there's some mics
floating around, which
I don't see the mic people.
So why don't we take a
question in the back,
and I can at least repeat it.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the things that I
hear is [INAUDIBLE] women in
technology is the [INAUDIBLE].
But one thing I hear
constantly mirroring
that is an unwillingness
for the tech industry
to be really honest
about how they
compensate their employees.
Companies don't want
to tell other companies
how much they pay their people.
Where I work, we're
actually encouraged
not to talk about what
our grade level is,
or whether we got promoted.
You're basically trying to
encourage your employees
to hide this information
from each other,
so that you can wage
suppress the people you
don't want to promote.
And I feel like
women in technology
should be standing
up to companies
and saying that that's not
an acceptable practice, not
just for women, but for any
diverse group of people,
because I don't
understand any benefit,
other than to
discriminate, that there
is in hiding people's
accomplishments
from each other.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Yeah.
I agree.
The research definitely
needs to be done.
Even if you're taking
everyone's name out of it,
and analyzing it based on,
hey, similar job titles, this
is what's making.
Do we have a problem?
Hopefully, there are some
companies out there like,
no, we have no problems at all.
That's my goal.
But if there is, it goes
back to what I said earlier.
You're asking someone
to increase wages,
but that's actually a
long-term investment.
And so if companies
can be thinking,
hey, we're going
to keep this person
in the industry for
another 20 years,
they might stay at this
company for 10 of those years,
then it's actually fiscally
responsible for leadership
to make those decisions.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'm a software engineer.
I work at Adobe, great company,
but the upper management
tends to be shy men
who in a social setting
don't even make eye
contact with me.
And I feel that affects me.
And when it comes,
like you said,
oh, these two people are
great, who do we promote,
well, my [INAUDIBLE] level
manager doesn't know me,
so the other person
gets promoted.
I have asked a few people
here how they deal with this,
but I don't know about chili
cook-offs, and barbecues,
and Teslas, so I don't
know how to start
a conversation with these
heavyweights who are male,
but they're shy,
or whatever it is.
So I'm looking for some
guidance on what are good ways
to start a conversation with
such people who actually
have a say in my promotion?
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Yeah.
So I'd think generally
finding some small ask,
because they're shy.
They're very busy
probably as well.
And then breaking the ice,
because they're probably acting
that way because they're shy.
So finding something that
they can do in 5 or 10 minutes
to get that ball rolling.
And then once the relationship
slowly starts to develop,
you can ask for something
that maybe will take slightly
more time the next time.
But really making it as
easy as possible for them,
and making it something
that they can execute on
very quickly, because they
probably want to be involved,
and they want to help you, but
they haven't figured out how.
And as you said, they're
probably very shy.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm a user
experience designer.
And the company
that I work for is--
so all the people at the top
are men, like most of the time.
The biggest thing for me
has been that I recently
had a child, and
I wanted to make
some sort of minor adjustment
to my working situation.
I wanted four days a
week instead of five.
There's tons of data that says
that people that work minorly
reduced hours are actually
just as productive, if not more
productive, because
you have good reasons
to get your stuff
done even better,
so that you can have that
extra time with, let's say,
your child, or for whatever
reason you want reduced hours.
The tech companies are
super against that.
And I am fighting a
terrible uphill battle
that I may, in a
few months, decide
to just quit, because
they're really against it.
And I don't understand,
from my point of view,
why they wouldn't even
consider trying it.
They're just dead
set against it.
They don't even want to
try it, when wouldn't it
be in their best
interest to have
me be happy for a few years
where my child is young,
and then I will continue to stay
with them, because why wouldn't
I be 10 times more loyal to
a company that is actually
working with me, and
what I feel I need
for my schedule and my sanity,
and my child to grow up
to see me a little bit more?
But it's a terrible
uphill battle
that I have absolutely no
idea how to proceed on.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Yeah.
I mean, this is the kind of
thing that goes back to the,
hey, it is fiscally responsible.
It will keep you in your career.
It's a small thing,
and it's something
that we are asking
companies to do.
And it goes back to
what I said earlier.
Hey, we're realizing that
our power is actually
going to be in influencing
the companies that support us.
And the companies want
to know what to do.
And so creating a list,
or a story of the things
that need to be
done, companies are
going to do at least the
easy things, and some
of the hard things.
I think that this is
devastating to hear.
The wonderful thing about
software engineering
is, actually, it's
incredibly flexible,
or at least it has the potential
to be incredibly flexible.
And so when I hear numbers that
women are leaving at a higher
rate than they are
other industries,
that should be flip-flopped.
We should see that women are
staying in tech, in engineering
positions at a higher rate
than all other industries,
because you can't be a
pharmacist and work from home.
Or you can't be a teacher
and come in at 9 o'clock
and leave at 3:00, and then
work a few hours in the evening.
But you can do that with tech.
JULIE PEARL: So we'll
take one more question,
and then we're going
to be out of time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's [INAUDIBLE].
I'm from Netflix.
And this whole
10-year dropout, we've
focused a lot about keeping
people in the companies.
But what about those, like
myself, who actually left?
And I stayed at home for three
years to look after my kids.
Then when I came back in, it's
this really daunting prospect.
It's like everything's
moved on without you.
I have no idea where to go.
So one of the things which
I'm trying to look into
is setting up, things
for women like me,
such as an access portal
for all the internships
that are out there, for all
the open source that they
can get into.
But what else can we be
doing, both as a company
and individually?
ALAINA PERCIVAL:
Well, certainly,
coming to Women Who Code.
Actually, it's a
great opportunity
for women who have
technical backgrounds.
The nice thing about
software engineering
is, hey, what you've
known in the past is still
going to build on
what you need to know.
And had you stayed
in the industry,
you probably would have
learned three new things
in between the time
that you left and now.
And I mean, there's always
new languages coming out,
always new technologies-- web,
now mobile, and Swift, and Go.
And so you're always
learning something new.
And so you're in a great
position to reenter the market.
And you just have to get back
into a programming language
that interests you.
And it's completely possible.
There's tremendous
number of resources,
like Women Who Code, that
are going to help you
do that process.
And then again-- shameless
plug-- Woman Who Code,
we have over five
free events for women
here in the Bay Area
every single week.
And they're always at
different tech companies.
And they're always hiring.
And so you at least get
exposure into seeing
what the startup
cultures are like, what
the job opportunities are.
Last year, we were at
a Woman Who Code event.
And there was a director
of engineering there.
And a week and a half later,
he was like, oh, Alaina, I'm
hiring Rebecca.
And she'd essentially
had her first interview
by just chatting
with him, asking
about their technical
stack, asking
a couple of smart questions.
And within a week and a
half, that hiring decision
had already been made.
And so, I mean, we're incredibly
lucky here in the Bay Area
to have so many resources,
and so many tech companies.
So I mean, it's completely
possible for you to do.
We welcome you back.
We're really excited that
you're interested to come back.
AUDIENCE: So I've actually come
back for a year and a half.
I was really lucky.
But that was the thing.
I felt that I was lucky
to have this scenario.
And I've chatted
to other women that
have been struggling
really hard, both mentally,
because it's such
a daunting task,
and knowing where to start.
Who do you talk to?
Where's that first step to take?
And so Women Who Code
is fantastic for that.
And I do applaud you.
I'm part of it myself.
And it's a fantastic resource,
which I did use to come back.
So, thank you very
much for that.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE PEARL: I
want to thank you.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Thank you.
JULIE PEARL: Spending your time.
This was really fantastic.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: It's been
such an honor to be here today.
It's great to see so many
amazing technical women
in a room, so many
smart women in the room.
So thank you very much.
JULIE PEARL: Thank you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]